Transcriber: Melis Karadag
Gözden geçirme: Emel Çırakoğlu
Merhaba.
Bugün, dünyamızda atılan
küçük adımlarla nasıl
dünyamızı daha sürdürülebilir bir hale
getirebileceğimizden bahsetmek istiyorum.
Öncelikle, dünyamızda sınırsızmışçasına
kullandığımız bir sürü kaynak var.
Bunlara tükenebilir kaynak
adını veriyoruz.
Bunlar kullanıldığı zaman
yerine gelemeyen, oluşum gösteremeyen veya
oluşması çok çok uzun süren kaynaklar.
Bunların en başında suyun gelmesiyle
beraber, yine çok önemli olan
fosil yakıtlar, petrol, taş kömürü,
linyit, bor gibi kaynaklar da var.
Bunların hepsi tükenebilmekte.
Ama biz yine de bunların hepsini
bilinçsiz bir şekilde harcıyoruz.
Hiç düşündünüz mü?
Bize anaokulundan beri
ailelerimiz, çevremiz,
öğretmenlerimiz tarafından devamlı
dişini fırçalarken suyu kapat,
kullanmadığın elektriği söndür
veya elini sabunlarken suyu açık bırakma
gibi öğütler veriliyor.
Veya sokaktan geçen birine
“Tasarruf nedir?” diye sorsanız,
“Elektriği az kullanmak.”
gibi bir cevap alabilirsiniz.
Peki, biz yıllardır aklımızda
bu kadar yer etmiş olan eylemleri
gerçekten hayatımızda uyguluyor muyuz?
Tekrar kendinize bunu sormanızı istiyorum.
Bahsettiğim küçük ama
etkisi büyük eylemleri
kimimiz uyguluyor,
kimimiz uygulamıyor olsak da
ülkemizde ve dünyamızda
bunlarla ilgili çalışmalar yapılmakta.
Ben de bu çalışmalara katkı gösteren,
işini çok büyük bir özenle yapan
bir Türk kadınından bahsetmek istiyorum:
Aynur Acı Onur.
Aynur Onur, Türkiye’de
ODTÜ’den mezun olduktan sonra,
yüksek lisansını
antropoloji üzerine yapmak üzere
burslu bir şekilde
Indiana Üniversitesi’ne, Amerika’ya gitti.
Burada doktoraya kabul aldıktan sonra da
askeri antropoloji üzerine yoğunlaştı.
Fakat daha sonra Türkiye’ye, aile köyü
olan Kayalı köyüne döndü.
Burdur’un Karamanlı ilçesinin Kayalı Köyü.
Burada, özellikle kuraklıkta ve
suyun korunmasında
çok önemli bir rol oynayacağını düşündüğü
Susuz Tarım Projesi’ni başlattı.
Böylece hem suyu koruyor
hem de verim alıyordu.
Susuz tarım nedir diye soracak olursanız,
sadece yağmur ve kar yağışından
faydalanılarak,
onun dışında herhangi bir sulama
yapılmadan kullanılan bir tarım yöntemi.
Böylece fide ve tohumun dikimi esnasında
verilen can suyu dışında
herhangi bir sulama yapılmıyor.
Böylece suyu korumadaki katkısını ve
ileride kuraklıktaki olan görülecekteki
katkısını da anlayabilirsiniz.
Peki, sizce bir kadın Amerika’daki bütün
başarısını ve hayatını geride bırakıp
aile köyüne dönüp
Susuz Tarım Projesi’ni başlatabildiyse,
biz de bir adım atamaz mıyız?
Bizim yapacağımız küçücük şeyler bile
gerçekten çok büyük farklar yaratabiliyor.
Atık yönetimi, kaynak paylaşımı, kaynak
kullanımın azaltılması, geri dönüşüm ve
yeniden kullanmak bile gerçekten çok
büyük katkılar sağlayabiliyor.
Şimdi de size, dünyada
sürdürülebilirlik adına yapılan bir
anlaşmadan bahsetmek istiyorum:
Paris İklim Anlaşması.
Bu anlaşma iklim değişikliğinin
azaltılması, adaptasyonu ve finansmanı
hakkında 2015 yılında imzalanan, 2016
yılında da yürürlüğe giren bir anlaşma.
Bu da Birleşik Milletler İklim Değişikliği
Sözleşmesi’nin 191 üyesi
tarafından bu anlaşmaya taraf olmuşlar.
Bunun yanı sıra,
ulusal anlamda da ülkemizde birçok proje
gerçekleştirilmiş ve gerçekleştirilmekte.
Ben de 2021 Sürdürülebilirlik İş
Ödülleri’nde ödül almış
birkaç tane örnek vermek istiyorum.
Birincisi Vestel Beyaz Eşya’nın
mikrofiber filtreli çamaşır makinesi;
ikinci, Roteks Tekstil’in
sıfır simyasal kullanarak,
kumaş atıklarından ceplik geliştirilmesi;
son olarak da Arçelik ve LG Klima’nın,
rapid hammaddesinin geliştirilmesi ve
kullanımı ile klima ürününün
sürdürülebilirlik yolculuğundaki
fark yaratması
ödül alan birkaç projeye örnek.
Peki, biz ne yapabiliriz?
Bugünün gençleri, yarının büyükleri
olarak ne yapabiliriz?
İlla bir şirket mi olmamız gerekiyor?
İlla bir topluluk mu olmamız gerekiyor?
Hayır.
Bize çocukluğumuzdan beri verilen
talimatlar suyu kapat, ışığı kapat gibi;
bunlara uymamız ve sürdürülebilir yaşama
katkı sağlayacak en ufak şey bile
gerçekten çok büyük katkılar
sağlayabiliyor.
Ben de bu konuşmayı hazırlarken
Aynur Onur'la yeni tanıştım.
Ona, bana farkındalık kattığı için
gerçekten çok teşekkür ediyorum.
Aynı zamanda bana çocukluğumdan beri
örnek olan aileme ve öğretmenlerime de
çok teşekkür etmek istiyorum.
Peki kendime dönüp baktığım
zaman, duyarlı mıydım?
Evet, duyarlıydım.
Ama bu çalışmayı yaptıktan sonra da
kendime,
ülkem ve dünyam için
daha duyarlı olacağıma söz veriyorum.
Sizi de sürdürülebilir bir dünya için
bana eşlik etmeye davet ediyorum.
Çünkü bu dünyaya ihtiyacımız var.
Çok teşekkür ediyorum.